For those who predict
the American experiment can't last,
and who worry the social
fabric is disintegrating
at a time of rising political division,
it's worth remembering that back
when the ink had barely
dried on the Constitution,
the Founding Fathers
were deeply pessimistic
about the future of the
country they had created.
Hamilton called the Constitution,
"A frail and worthless fabric."
Washington lamented the
growth of political factions.
Adams thought a lack of civic
virtue doomed the Republic.
Jefferson watched sectional divisions
between North and South with horror,
calling the sacrifices made by
the generation of '76 "useless
because it would be
thrown away by the unwise
and unworthy passions of their sons.
"My only consolation," he wrote,
"is to be that I live
not to weep over it."
Their pronouncements
seem almost histrionic
to the modern ear.
In "Fears Of A Setting Sun,"
Syracuse University Professor
Dennis Rasmussen wrestles
with the Founders near universal pessimism
about the future of the
country they created.
Partly I think that's because they thought
that so much was at stake.
They really thought that the
future of Republican government
and the future of human liberty was riding
on this American experiment.
And so the potential
failure of that experiment,
they thought would be a
world historical calamity.
I mean, they did have
really grandiose hopes.
You read what they write,
and they really think they're
coming up with a new system
that's gonna secure liberty for the future
that had never been done before.
They're worried that what they think
of this world historical
achievement is going to fail.
It's not just Washington,
Hamilton, Adams, and Jefferson-
virtually all of the Founders who lived
into the 19th century became disillusioned
for one reason or another.
Only one Founder stood
out as an exception.
So, I'll confess,
I assumed that Madison
would be disillusioned too.
I initially set out to write a book
about five disillusioned Founders,
but really his final years were ones
of almost defiant optimism.
Part of it is just temperament.
He had a more even-keeled temperament
than the other Founders did.
Part of it was that he just expected less
from politics than they did.
He didn't have the sometimes
grandiose or utopian hopes
that some of the other Founders did.
And one of them really, I think,
is just that he had lived so long.
He's the one who outlives
all the other Founders.
He lives until 1836.
By the end of his life,
the country had weathered a
half centuries worth of storms.
And he thought, well,
the longer it endures,
the more durable it seems.
Should Americans see
the Founders disillusion
as a sign that America
is flawed beyond hope?
After all, we are still beset
by many of the fears
the Founders identified.
I think the fact that their
worries are still with us,
but that the country is still with us,
the Constitution is still with us,
you could take in either
of two directions.
On the one hand, you could say,
well, the country has lasted this long
despite these problems.
It's probably, as Madison suggested,
going to last a good deal longer.
We can live with these problems in a way
that we sometimes don't
think we can, right?
We hear people pronounce the end
of American democracy at every turn.
And the fact that it hasn't ended
in the past 230 years suggests
that maybe Madison was right
and it'll last a good deal longer.
On the other hand,
these problems probably aren't going away.
We sometimes seem to think
that with the right tweak
to the political system,
if we just, you know,
get rid of the electoral
college or the filibuster
or whatever the pet worry
is, then all will be right.
Then American politics will be fixed.
But the fact that these
problems have been with us
since the very outset, since
the Founders themselves,
suggests that, you know,
they might be more systemic,
more baked in than we
sometimes dare to hope.